Hoy hablaremos sobre los segmentos de clientes.
żPara quiénes están creando su propuesta de valor?
żCuáles trabajos quieren los clientes que hagan por ellos?
żCuáles problemas desean resolver y cuales beneficios quieren ver?
Y al final de esto, lo que ustedes desean encontrar es el arquetipo o la personalidad pública
de ese alguien para quien están creando el producto.
La última vez hablamos de las propuestas de valor,
pero hoy nos vamos a centrar en los segmentos de clientes.
Una de las cosas interesantes sobre los clientes
es que los clientes no existen para comprar, de hecho, ustedes existen para ellos.
Y, especialmente, si tienen una startup de tecnología,
es realmente difícil, porque ustedes siempre piensan que se trata de su producto
y es difícil recordar que, de hecho, se trata de las personas al otro lado del proceso
que son las que van a comprar.
Entonces, una de las cosas que realmente deben comprender es quiénes son
y por qué les van a comprar.
Y uno de los objetivos de los segmentos de clientes es tratar de entender el arquetipo
o la personalidad pública o quizás los detalles de quiénes son estas personas en detalle.
Quieren saber dónde viven, qué hacen, qué edad tienen,
si están en zona urbana, si están casados, etc.
żY por qué lo quieren saber?
Porque esto les ayudará a no embarcarse en tareas imposibles
tratando de incluir a todo el mundo para que compre su producto.
Por el contrario, averiguar específicamente quiénes están interesados y por qué
facilita demasiado la venta y hace que ellos deseen su producto,
cuando ustedes comprendan quiénes son y cuáles son sus motivaciones.
Entonces, es por esto que invertimos todo este tiempo hablando sobre los clientes y los segmentos de clientes.
Una de las cosas que verán más adelante en esta clase
es que, de hecho, podrían tener múltiples segmentos de clientes,
es decir, diversos tipos de clientes, todos interesados en su producto.
Podrían ser hombres de 18 a 24 ańos que viven en zonas urbanas,
pero, en algunos casos, también podrían tener mujeres de 45 a 55 ańos
que viven en zonas rurales y que también estén interesadas.
Y los tipos de comercialización o creación de demanda que empleará para atraer a cada segmento
serán diferentes. Pero si ustedes no supieran quiénes son,
estarían creando el mismo tipo de mercadeo y, de hecho, probablemente no llegarían a ninguno de ellos.
Entonces, examinémoslo con más detenimiento.